should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
they attack the minds of of our of
people really and especially young minds
from both ways it's on the one hand this
apocalyptic like the whole world is
going to come to an end a really
alarmist
um story and then on the other hand on
the individual level it's an anything
ghost story everything is relative you
know there's just there's your truth
there's my truth there's nothing such as
an absolute truth you know there's no
God there's no uh no real morality
everything goes and that combination is
so incredibly deadly and that's why I
think it's so important what you're
doing with this and we need to counter
it the most intense and totalitarian
tyranny will necessarily emerge in the
midst of the most fragmented and
individualized population you can't have
a tyranny without fractionated
individuals and it is it is a perverse
marriage right of that intense
subjective so-called Freedom with this
insane top-down International
distant tyranny and we're definitely
drifting in that direction super fast
again with massive people coming from
massive numbers of countries into places
like the United States and all across
the EU that creates that fracture not at
the
personal uh level in one mind but in in
the whole population you know nobody's
going to be able to come together like
you aren't going to have Dutch farmers
and Netherlands they're going to be able
to stand up because they're going to be
replaced right and then you're going to
have a bunch of people from Somalia and
other places that are all mixed together
they'll they won't have any centralized
ability to organize perfect slaves I
mean this is very easy this is what they
say they're going to do
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I'm pleased today to have
the opportunity to have a discussion
with Michael yawn who's one of the
world's great roving journalists he's
been in all the hell holes around the
world maybe not all of them but a good
proportion of them over the last few
decades and he's written for many of the
major news outlets across the world at
the moment he's in the Netherlands
covering the Dutch Farmers protest among
other things he's accompanied by Eva
vlardinger Brooke who who is a a
political figure in in Europe in the
Netherlands and um they've been both
attending the Dutch farmer protests and
I wanted to get them together today to
talk about well why anyone should care
about the fact that Dutch farmers are
protesting how many of them are
protesting what it means um and uh what
the broader issues are at stake because
what's happening in the Netherlands is a
reflection of uh
socio-political struggle that's going on
at a very deep level between World Views
that are truly in opposition and the
Dutch farmer protest in my estimation is
a what would you say it's a microcosm of
a much larger battle that's raging and
will continue to range for the next
while rage for the next while so Michael
maybe let's start with you uh how long
have you been in the Netherlands now in
in this span of time
well during this trip in particular I've
been back for about one week as you know
you were we were together you and I were
together here last year and I came on
your podcast last year I was down in
Mexico watching the migration if you
want to call it that into Texas and then
I saw that the Dutch farmers were
blocking the streets in in Netherlands
and having lived in Europe for more than
six years I realized that was
significant so I jumped on an airplane I
left Mexico came straight here to the
Netherlands and went out to the first
farmers I could find blocking streets
and I said why are you blocking the
streets uh and so because you know in
every country that I go to around the
world I've spent more than half of my
life traveling around the world to
places like Afghanistan and Iraq and
India and I go straight to the farmers
and because that's where you get one of
the pulses right and and I said what's
going wrong here and they started
telling me and giving me an earful and I
realized we have a significant problem
and as you know I've written three books
on in unfortunately they're only in
Japanese language I wrote them in
English but they're about information
War right uh so I I I study information
more as you know information Wars the
PHD level of warfare all the kinetics
which I did for years in various Wars
Iraq Afghanistan whatever that's
certainly very important especially when
you're in it but the PHD level of
warfare is information war and I
realized that the Dutch were at an
epicenter of the information War as are
the Japanese that's why I wrote those
three books warning the Japanese that
they're the they are being targeted by
the CCP the Chinese Communist party in
an information campaign that's designed
to split the Koreans and the and the
Japanese and the Americans apart it's
now I wrote I started writing those
books in 2014 and in 2019 and 20 that
actually the split was was uh relatively
complete with the Japanese and the
Koreans all based on information work
I'll turn back to the information War
issue the Legacy media coverage of
what's happening in the uh in in the on
the Dutch farmer protest front because
that's relevant to the information War
but let's let's turn to Eva for a moment
Eva do you want to just explain to
people who you are and what you do and
how long you've been doing it and then
why you're interested in the Dutch
Farmers Pro protested how you got
tangled up with such a nefarious
character as Michael
well I'm Dutch so let's start there so I
was born and raised here and that's
partly why I'm so interested in the
cause of the Dutch Farmers so I've been
able to follow what has been happening
to them for years now because it's
important for people to know that even
though you know the protests of last
summer and the process that are
happening now are being televised quite
widely this is a fight that has been
going on for years you know our
government is really fighting a war of
attrition against our Farmers so that is
one um I have personally I have a
background in law I'm a legal
philosopher and my academic time wasn't
that long my University decided to kick
me out of my PhD program basically
because it was a deemed too
controversial politically speaking so I
decided to turn the other way and I have
been focusing on International media and
making videos and putting out my content
in English mostly and in German now but
so I'm mostly focused on the
international market I'm a conservative
commentator I could say and I've met
Michael we've met in person yesterday
actually for the first time but I've
seen Michael's work online and I admire
him immensely so I'm very happy to meet
him now finally Jordan
Ava was leading the way yesterday in the
uh there was some fear for some people
attending the protest uh in fact one of
the opposition parties the BB better
party build back better it's the how do
you say it in Dutch
right the the farmers yeah it's supposed
to mean citizen Farmers movement the
leader of that Caroline vanderplas she
she was afraid to attend the protest
yesterday and prayed for her safety she
said so what did Ava do she took the
front she took the front tractor and was
the first one to arrive uh in a tractor
yesterday so that was pretty uh good
leadership on your part it got everybody
psyched up so Eva are you are you
um you're primarily focusing on
political commentary do you have any
um official or traditional political
position or are you functioning
primarily as a investigative journalist
and commentator no I I function
independently from any political party
uh at the very moment at this very
moment I have been involved in such
politics briefly in parliamentary
politics but that really wasn't for me I
don't um want to be in that system again
and I really enjoy my newfound freedom
of being able to say exactly what I
think and what I want to say to the
world so I'm planning on keeping it this
way
okay so do you want to outline for the
people who are watching what you said
that the um the battle so to speak
between the Dutch farmers and the Dutch
government has been going on for quite a
long time now is it reasonable to
construe it as a battle between the
Dutch farmers and the Dutch government
or is it a a faction of farmers and a
faction of the government like I'd like
to know how widespread the discontent
among Dutch Farmers is and whether there
is a fracture within the farming
Community itself and then the same thing
obtains obviously at the political level
these things are seldom monolithic so
let's let's start with the farmers what
what what percentage of farmers are
upset what percentage are complaining
and why are they upset okay yeah I think
that there is not one Dutch farmer right
now that is not that is happy with the
Dutch government the current Dutch
cabinet so that's important to note it
is definitely a fight
um from the Dutch Farmers against the
government or the other way around I
should rather say everybody is upset and
of course there are differences within
the farmers there are people I I would
say the most important split between the
farmers that exist right now is the
group of farmers that is willing to
compromise that is willing to talk to
the government and say okay we'll still
negotiate and the group that is
completely done with that so I think the
most important split between those two
groups is the group that accepts The
Narrative of the idea that there is a
nitrogen crisis so to say and the group
that says no there isn't there is no
nitrogen crisis we have done everything
that you have asked of us for the past I
don't know at least three years now in
terms of you know reorganizing our
businesses doing everything that you
asked of us and you are still coming
after us and we are done so I think that
is probably ideologically also the most
important question in this in this war
that the government is waging against
our farmers do you still believe the
narrative that the government sense you
with or do you not
okay so let's let's go in two directions
there you talked about a nitrogen crisis
so we should outline what constitutes
the government narrative on the nitrogen
crisis side and you also mentioned that
a substantial proportion of the farmers
are now done with negotiating they feel
that they've been pushed to the wall
that they've done everything they
possibly could and that there's nothing
left but the opportunity to say no I
mean one of the things that struck me
about the Dutch Farmers protest
immediately was that I know farmers and
I know that modern farmers are very
sophisticated and they're also very hard
working and they don't have time to muck
around and the machinery for example
that they're using the tractors and so
forth to to
um to bring to the protests is extremely
expensive machinery and it's not uh it's
not generally within the easy means of a
farmer to put their Machinery to any
other use than productive use on the
farm and I know Dutch farmers are hyper
productive maybe the best in the world
or certainly among the best and so my
sense was that if the Dutch farmers are
upset a substantial proportion of them
they're like a canary in the coal mine
there's probably something to be upset
about but what percentage of the Dutch
farmers do you think are in a situation
where they're seriously done with
negotiation and then what does it mean
for people in a peaceful polity to be
done with negotiation right well let's
let's talk about what our government
wants to do so with this nitrogen crisis
that they say we now have they're saying
that they need to reduce nitrogen
emissions and what that comes down to is
that 50 of the Dutch farmers will have
to go by the year of 2030. those are
their goals so imagine you know if 50 of
the farmers have to go then hopefully
you'd think that 50 of all those farmers
in our country are done with our
government
um I think that would be a fair estimate
okay so to say okay
um and that means that at least 30
percent of the livestock will have to be
um abolished as well and our government
has been you know like I said it's been
a wharf attrition they've been doing
negotiations for all these years going
back and forth and in the last over the
last couple of months even more so but
what you can really see is our the
strategy of our government is always the
same they say oh we'll negotiate with
you you know they sit down with a group
of farmers that is maybe a bit more
moderate group you know rather than the
the people that go out to these rallies
for example that we were at yesterday
um and then they go back to the
boardroom they take a couple of extra
months you know nobody knows really
what's going on and then they come back
with a new reward and it says exactly
the same thing but with different words
and usually phrased a little bit nicer
you know but if you really read what it
says nothing ever changes actually the
last report that came out was a report
that doubled down so in the last report
what they said they use words that
confuse the population they use the word
saying that the peak polluters have to
go so 600 Peak polluters which would
include some other you know businesses
not just Farmers but some other
businesses as well predominantly Farmers
though 600 of them will have to go in
the next year see so you know we go from
cutting 50 by 2030 to now oh by the way
600 Peak polluters have to be gone in
the next year and we're not doing that
with expropriation no it all has to be
on a voluntary basis but you know the
reality of the matter is that nothing
about this is voluntary it's a war of
attrition they've been pushing these
Farmers to despair you know we've had so
many cases of farmers who've committed
suicide already
these people are being tormented by our
government and then if they end up
selling at the very end because their
license isn't renewed for example then
our government can still say that it was
voluntary but we all know that nothing
about this in fact is voluntary
during the season of Lent we are called
to abstain from luxuries and instead
more deeply embrace our faith co-workers
around the office have mentioned giving
up coffee alcohol and social media but
how about using this time to start
building a habit of prayer and
meditation
join me and thousands of others on
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the U.S hallow is helping me
maintain a daily prayer routine from now
until Easter and it can help you too
download the app for free at hallow.com
Jordan you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year available
on the Hallow app for brief daily Bible
readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes with Halo
you can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you and listen anywhere
you are with downloadable offline
sessions get an exclusive three-month
free trial at hallow.com Jordan that's
hallow.com Jordan
[Music]
okay so my understanding correct me if
I'm wrong is that
the part of the reason that the Dutch
government is down the necks on the next
let's say of the farmers is because
environmentalist activists have taken
the Dutch government to court to force
them to comply with European Union
top-down environmental apocalypse
um oriented uh uh European Union
regulations that that are aimed at
reducing let's say carbon output but
also reducing other forms of pollution
and now nitrogen pollution can be a
problem if excess fertilizer enters
waterways and so forth it can cause
algal blooms and and and obviously it's
the case that we want to pollute the
least amount possible well-growing food
so but why do you think like first of
all have I got that story right have
have the Dutch has the Dutch government
itself been cornered by the courts and
is that a consequence of European Union
pressure I think that they are very
happy that that happened though and they
go further than what the European Union
has told them to do so the Dutch
government isn't innocent in this case
you know they're not completely just
cornered by the courts they have gone
further than what Brussels has told them
to do so I think that is very important
because it shows you their true intent
and I think that the true intent that
the government has is to get rid of our
Farmers they want the land because they
need the land I'm sure we'll get that to
that in a bit but it's definitely I
would say that there's definitely intent
here and it goes further than just being
cornered by courts they they're they're
they've been cornered by the courts but
they're perfectly happy with that
cornering and they're willing to take it
farther so why do the why does the EU
and their and the courts and the
environmentalists and the government
have their panties in the knot so to
speak about nitrogen per se like what's
the problem exactly that they're trying
to address here and why do they think
that demolishing the farming industry is
going to solve that problem what's their
goal like if you had to frame it
positively what would their goal be well
the story is that they want to preserve
nature so there are designated areas in
the Netherlands that are natural
reserves so to say and they have decided
it's a political decision that that
landscape cannot change so it has to
remain the same uh it has to remain the
same as it was for example 25 years ago
so that means that certain sand dunes
for example can't have vegetation or
certain plants can't grow there it needs
to look exactly the same so they say
that that is to protect nature but it's
a political choice of how you want your
country to look how you want you know
the landscape the Countryside to look so
to me so at the start of this is real
yeah well so so they're they're pushing
the pristine nature narrative yes
fundamentally how many farmers do you
think are protesting at the moment
actively protesting in terms of absolute
numbers
I would think that's hard to say oh look
I will look at Michael for that as well
because we like I said we have 50 000
Farms
um and it's definitely not I wouldn't
say it's the majority because a lot of
people have already lost a fair bit of
Hope
um so what do you think Michael how many
farmers do you think are
currently protesting physically
protesting keeping in mind I do these
things around the world so most of the
people will be the support base that
never go to a protest so your support
base is always difficult to measure
actually but everybody all the farmers
that I speak with uh now uh Ava just
mentioned sort of apathy may have said
in or resignation that they may not be
able to uh to defeat this government
actually if we're talking about nitrogen
we're talking about the wrong level by
the way where if we're talking about the
details of this we're already losing
because this is not about stick stuff as
they call it here nitrogen this is about
taking those farms and making Tri-State
City Tri-State city is this giant City
you can see the maps you and I have
talked about it before when you're here
Jordan Tri-State city is called
Tri-State City because it will take most
or all of the Netherlands part of
Belgium and part of Germany into this
Mega smart City basically a control City
and it happens to end at Rotterdam which
is at the end of the rail head all the
way away from Shanghai so the railway
all the way from Shanghai China all the
way across Asia will go right through
the middle of Tri-State City and we'll
be sitting in Tri-State City right now
so you've got to take that Farmland if
we go back in history and we look what
Stalin did and and the Ukraine uh 32 and
33 in the whole lot of more uh one of
the things that he the main people that
he targeted were the kulaks the farmers
right so he did an information campaign
this is all about information War he
targeted the cool locks labeled the cool
locks labeling somebody at coolock was
like in a sense labeling them Jewish or
polish in different eras right or
similar same era actually but labeling
people cool Ox then using the
information War uh convinced people that
all their problems were the result of
the cool ox and if you just take their
Farms your problems will go away so
basically did a replacement strategy
right and so people came in killed the
kulaks and took their farms and had a
massive famine right because the ability
to farm I talked with a fisherman men
yesterday at the protest his family has
been fishing since the 1400s as far back
as he can track it right this is they
fishing and farming is what they know
how to do right so when you do these
replacement strategies for instance the
Mao did of course Mao studied Stalin uh
you've got to get rid of the farmers so
it's not about it's not just about has
nothing to do with nitrogen that's
completely irrelevant again if we're
talking nitrogen we're losing now on a
bigger picture you know that I study
migration deeply hop the human osmotic
pressure The Hop the human osmotic
pressure is the push and pull of the
migration I just left Darien I just left
the Darien Gap between Panama and
Colombia again that's why I addressed in
these funny clothes and so I was just
down there watching Chinese come through
in large numbers mostly military aged
males the Darian Gap is that area
between Colombia and South America
between Colombia and Panama where people
can it's an hourglass from Africa and
Asia and South America through Panama up
to the United States so we we have about
a thousand people a day coming through
there right now from about 140 countries
now back to work let's bring this back
to Netherlands there's a clear
replacement strategy going on that's
what Stalin did with a lot more right
replacing the cool locks that's what Mao
did that's what Pol Pot did that's what
so many other people that's what they're
working on now in South Africa and have
done in other African countries right
they're doing right now people are
coming in from about 140 countries just
through the dairy and GAP here in
Netherlands or let's go over to
Luxembourg a neighbor of Netherlands I
was there last year and approximately
half of the country now is actually
migrants you can see that on their
official website now the migrants who
are coming in are not monocultural it's
not just Afghans or pakistanis or
yemenis or something like that so the
divide and conquer is already done in
that regard for instance one pig farmer
that I was with in Netherlands last week
uh I asked if he's hiring any migrants
he said yes he had a bunch of Afghans
who were great workers he said and uh
but then they suddenly got their
residence cards to live in Netherlands
and now they're getting paid to stay
here so they had to quit their work
right he grows pigs in pears and
Christmas trees so then he hired some
other people from Africa and other
countries uh Ukraine and other places
but he hires people from from different
countries that are migrants right but
now they're already prepping and and Ava
can talk more about this they're
prepping the Dutch mind and they're
doing the same in Finland and other
places to start taking in uh migrants
into your homes they're not doing it yet
they're not ordering it but Ava can can
talk more about this but there is a law
in the Dutch books that in the case of
emergency you'll have to take people
into your homes right and they're
prepping this now in the news Cycles
like you know they're not doing it but
just to put that in the back your mind
one lady that lives in a big Farmhouse
after her family is gone her husband has
died she doesn't need that big Farmhouse
she can bring in some somalis to live
with her right they're prepping a
replacement strategy it's right in your
face it's writing your grill I was down
in Morocco last year Watching uh the the
Moroccan government push people to suta
and melilla which were two Spanish
cities that are in Morocco and I was
down in Greece watching the Turks push
them over the border into into Greece I
was up in Lithuania watching Belarus
that's when I started warning that
something was about to happen when we
saw the when we saw the uh the
belarusians pushing migrants they tried
to push them into Poland Poland did not
allow it of course and then Lithuania
allowed some in I was up there for five
weeks the lithuanians gave me complete
access to their camps because I I know
people in the Lithuanian Army because I
was with them in Afghanistan so they
gave me complete access to the camps
into the border and to their their
intelligence people and their army and
whatnot and they had this was a clear
weaponization of migration it's
weaponization of migration this has gone
on since forever again that's what
what's the what's the goal what okay so
so Michael now you've opened up like 15
different counts of worms so let me walk
through a couple of of them I have a
specific question for you and for Eva
first of all if the Dutch government
manages to eliminate 50 percent of
farmers and 30 percent of livestock by
2030 which is pretty much tomorrow why
do they think that the entire
infrastructure that supports the
agricultural industry in the Netherlands
Will Survive because there's obviously a
whole supply chain that's dependent on
the Dutch farmer production and they're
going to be running on very tight
margins and that would include grocery
stores and food processing plants and
all of that and if they lose 50 percent
of their inputs well they're going to
collapse there's not going to be half of
them left there's going to be zero of
them left and so is that being taken
into account in the government plans and
then
and then what do the what does the Dutch
government make of the fact that well
you know Dutch people need food and
maybe they need local food and there's
no there's every bit of evidence to
assume that the Dutch farmers can
provide food much more efficiently and
with much less pollution than Farmers
anywhere else because food's going to
have to be imported like is there a
vision at all on the government side for
what's going to happen when the entire
food supply infrastructure is stressed
and threatened by their lack of the
farmers and the lack of the livestock
and what and are they giving no Credence
whatsoever to the necessity for food
security it's very weird in Holland
since it had a bloody famine just after
World War II so what's going on in the
food provision front even maybe you
could take it up for a second and then
I'll return to some of Michael's
comments yeah I don't think they care
about that and that's exactly the
problem so it shows you what their true
agenda behind all of this is and as
Michael said that is an agenda of
control so I think the Dutch farmers are
being targeted for two reasons one of
them being that our Farmers like you
said they're so effective you know
they're such good
um we're the second largest exporter of
agricultural products and we're such a
tiny country you would think that this
sector is celebrated by our government
the fact that it's not the fact that
it's under attack is to a rational mind
just completely insane really you know
it's insane and so you have to start
thinking what is the real reason that
they're doing this then why would you
start coming after farmers in a time of
food scarcity and that's where you come
to the question of intent and I know
that people find that to be a scary
question I understand that people are
like oh well this is you know we live in
a liberal democracy we're in the Western
World our government would never want us
to be hungry our government would never
want us to starve well I think that that
is plain wrong I think if you control
the food supply you control the people
and our government knows that just as
well as China does you know that is not
something that has left the modern mind
so to say of the people who rule us and
our farmers are quite frankly the only
people with the courage and the manpower
to stand up to our government they are
an independent group they function uh
freely you know without help of the
government oftentimes they are hard
working they are Christian they
represent the Dutch Spirit more than
just you know an agricultural sector
they represent I would say our culture
as a nation you know they're a very very
important group oftentimes these
businesses have been in Dutch families
for centuries on end it is the backbone
of our society so I think that that is
one of the main reasons why they want
them gone you know really it's an attack
on our identity so so now
okay now Michael made a complex case for
intent and I'm going to return to that
but I want to make a simpler case for
intent and then I want to discuss this
the idea of of the the Tri-City for
example and and the and the uh the the
the the theft of land from the farmers
and what might be behind that so when I
look at what's happening on the woke
environmentalist front what I
fundamentally see are venal politicians
who are not very competent at anything
except attempting to look competent in a
narcissistic way
that manipulate opinion polls and and
public opinion in general
so that they can appear as though
they're providing people with what they
want now I saw this on the coven front
so for example in Canada I talked to
senior advisors of of even conservative
governments in Canada who told me flat
out and to their own great shame that
all the coveted policy lockdowns were
driven 100 by opinion polls 100 percent
and then Justified with science post-hoc
and I found that out with a reporter
friend of mine who's a brilliant
political analyst and who's been doing
it for decades and I got to tell you
that that was shocking to both of us
that it had actually got to that extreme
and so what I see happening on the
political front is as I said there's
politicians who really have no long-term
Vision they're trying to cling to power
in one way or another they can cotton on
to this environmentalist ethos where
they're protecting the virginal Planet
they're looking like Heroes it doesn't
take any effort on their part they can
tell other people what to do and that's
and they looked like they're actually
making progress towards some desired end
and then they can frighten people with
idiot apocalyptic narratives and because
people are frightened they consider any
environmental movement forward as
positive and of course people like parks
and nature and that sort of thing so
it's not that hard to sell
it isn't obvious to me that it's
necessary to dig for deeper motives in
the way that Michael is digging and
we'll turn to that because I'm obviously
going to give him full Reign to to
justify his apprehensions when you're
looking at deeper intent like you're
alluding to the idea that there's some
plot to let's say to destroy core Dutch
identity
what what do you think is behind this
other than other than ignorance and and
narcissistic venality
um and what do you think of the of the
of the Tri-City hypothesis for example
and the notion that this is actually a
planned program to depopulate the farm
area so that the land can be turned over
to well to whoever it is that's
interested in getting control of it oh I
think there is definitely nothing
conspiratorial about the idea that our
government you know caters to the
interests of globalists rather than to
the people you know if they were to
listen to what the vox populi says they
wouldn't do this I would say that the
majority of Dutch people although you
will never hear that in the mainstream
media do not agree with this you know
they don't think that expropriation is a
good thing but they are being
indoctrinated uh from all sides that
this in fact will help nature that this
in fact will help the climate and so the
fact that all the models that our
government is using to calculate these
nitrogen emissions that they are faulty
that they are wrong which I think does
show you you know that they are aware of
the fact that this is a premise that
this is not actually their their actual
agenda
um you know I think that that is that
shows you that they don't have our best
interests at heart so I think that is
it's very safe to say that that is not
you know a conspiracy in any way shape
or form then the you know the fine
financial and political game that they
will get when they are able to seize
these Farmers is that our country is a
small country but 80 percent of it is
made up out of Farmland so imagine what
the state could do with that lens you
know what type of benefits that would
bring them and of course you know the
they're happy to push this this agenda
virtually like oh look at us protecting
nature and that is something that the
mainstream media will also push so that
is almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
right so right absolutely well okay so
in Canada I believe it's it's clearly
the case that
prime minister Justin Trudeau and Deputy
Prime Minister Freeland and also the
Socialist hypothetically yeah I mean
Singh who's propping up the Trudeau
government are aficionados of the Wes of
the world economic Forum that's
absolutely crystal clear and
um Trudeau has put forth a set of
policies uh just transition recently
that are essentially aimed at
eviscerating the Canadian energy
industry demolishing the foresty
industry and doing exactly the same
thing to the Canadian Farmers that the
Dutch government is doing to the to the
Dutch Farmers they've called for a 35
reduction in fertilizer use across the
board independent of how much fertilizer
any given farmer uses per unit of food
not knowing at all that the farmers have
strived diligently for the last six
decades to be so hyper efficient with
fertilizer use because it's expensive
not least that that it Beggars
description I mean they use satellite
technology in their fertilizer in the
machines that distribute the fertilizer
to make sure that that it's never
overused it's and they're unbelievably
productive but all of that's going by
the wayside and it is definitely because
as far as I can tell because Trudeau and
Freeland and Singh are trying to please
their globalist masters and they don't
give a damn about Canada as a nation
because as our own prime minister has
said the whole idea of the nation-state
is archaic and anachronistic and also
dangerous and uh so you think the same
thing is happening on the absolutely on
the on the Dutch side and so what do you
think what do you think is characterize
the globalist agenda for me
well let's first say that Trudeau and
Margarita are prime minister you know
are I would say almost basically the
same person in terms of their political
agenda their political ideas you know
they've been seen holding hands and and
hugging during the pandemic when they
told everybody else to stay uh at least
a meter and a half apart from each other
and they were cracking down on our
constitutional rights so Canada and the
Netherlands are both pilot countries for
the wef we are both pilot countries for
the Globus agenda but I think that the
Netherlands is maybe even an easier
Target because we are already part in a
way of a supranational organization
which is the EU you know all of these
policies come from the European Union
and they obviously base their policies
again on the sustainable development
goals that come from the United Nations
and the world economic Forum adopts us
as well so I you know when I hear you
talk about Trudeau it's as if it's as if
I hear you talk about Margarita they're
quite literally the same person when it
comes to ideology so that is that is
really important to know and these
people cater to that globalist ideal
which I think they are able to sell
again to the population with this
fake um idea of virtue so if you look
for example at the sustainable
development goals of the United Nations
you know there there are 30 of them or
17 I think 17 sustainable development
goals all of them if you look at them
sound wonderful you know you you would
think oh this is perfect of course I
want to I don't want anybody to be
hungry of course we want to abolish
poverty uh worldwide of course we want
the Sexes to have equal opportunities
but the answer is always a Crackdown on
actually your freedom and on being Dutch
Can you can you tell back to the killing
your identity can you tell Jordan about
how the Dutch government does not even
want you to use the word word Holland
anymore absolutely yeah no I mean we are
our prime minister will not stop I think
until we don't have a border anymore I
mean technically you know our border
doesn't mean anything already with all
the mass migration that we have coming
in which Michael did make a fair point
about for example last year we broke a
migration record again 450 400 000
people came into our tiny little piece
of land that is already so incredibly
densely populated the majority of the
Dutch people have been against how many
people are there in Holland well we have
about 18 million people what's what's
the population million and we are about
half the size of the American state of
Indiana to the point of the borders and
stealing national identity just
yesterday uh that the protests where you
led the way uh where some people
chickened out but you took the lead
truck uh they're excellent uh while that
protest was going on the the uh
Extinction Rebellion tried to interrupt
the protest that we were at which was
very peaceful and a very happy event
actually the one that we were at with
five or ten thousand people I don't even
know how many were there
um
the extension Rebellion were blocked was
blocking a12 right Highway a12 and so
the German the the Dutch police actually
asked the German policy to send water
cannons over which they did they sent
water cannon trucks from Germany
pulitzai were driving in you know pulled
his trucks and they started spraying
down Dutch protesters this is amazing to
think about you would never have thought
that 80 years ago Jordan forces again in
a military sense with the Germans but
now we have and one of the trucks in a
Spate of just irony it was it was hun 2
hun 2 you know basically the Huns are in
Netherlands oh wow wow you can't even
make up this stuff I think I sent it to
you Jordan so they they took the side of
Extinction Rebellion essentially which
is as radical and environment no no they
were spraying extension they were they
were they were spraying Extinction
Rebellion but the funny thing is is that
the that the German police were in
Netherlands using their water cannon
yesterday
so even from like a legal perspective
most what's important I think to know
for a country like mine in any country
in the European Union is that a lot of
our laws already don't aren't made in
our country you know they come from the
European Union so that democratically
leaves a huge gap between the citizen
and the laws that come in and then in my
country specifically any international
law is has more legal power than the
national law what how is that for
democracy right so just that mere fact
shows you I think you know that we can
no longer speak of a really strong
national identity and democracy in that
sense
well you know you know I was in is in
the Netherlands about five years ago
talking to a group of Dutch
intellectuals comedians artists and so
forth and one of the things they told me
was that they were having very doubt
very they were having very grave doubts
about the Integrity of the Dutch
identity and that really came as a shock
to me because as a Canadian I I come
from this little town in Northern
Alberta which is only about 50 years old
and Canada especially western Canada is
a very very new country and so when I
come to a place like Holland and I hear
the Dutch people especially the
intellectuals and the artistic leaders
expressed doubts about the Integrity of
their culture it's just absolutely
shocking to me because when I come in as
an outsider I think Holland is one of
the great cultures has one of the great
cultures of the world but
technologically because your Society
runs so smoothly it's an absolute bloody
Miracle especially because you should be
underwater and then culturally as well I
mean Amsterdam is an absolutely
beautiful city it has a rich artistic
tradition a rich religious tradition and
if if you if you Dutch are starting to
doubt the validity of your own identity
there's no hope for oh let's say for
Canadians and of course our prime
minister has already famously announced
that Canada has no core identity and
that we're the first post-national state
and so but how do you Eva how do you
read the fundamental motivation of the
globalists I mean you talked about the
sustainable development goals and I I
have to admit or also pronounce that I
helped write the original sustainable
goal document and that was probably 10
years ago and in my defense I can tell
you that the drafts that were produced
before the team that I was working on
rewrote them were a hell of a lot more
vicious and Troublesome than the drafts
that uh we ended up with I we took a lot
of idiotic Cold War uh pro-socialists
Pros out of the descriptions and tried
to make sense out of it I came out of
that with a sense that I was
extraordinarily confused at the
multitude of the goals because there was
no prioritization and also about the
potential danger of of precisely the
top-down machinations that you're
describing but as you said if you look
at the sustainable development goals one
by one it's very difficult to take issue
with them they'd all look positive
the problem is is that they are they're
converted into top-down policy that's
that's implemented by force and you
pointed out something else that's
extraordinarily Troublesome which is
that as we move toward International
governance which is obviously necessary
at some to some degree because Nations
have to communicate we're moving the
distance between people at the local
level like the Dutch farmers and those
who putatively govern them were putting
in such a distance between them in terms
of communication that there is no
communication there's just top-down
edict that's a real Tower of Babel
situation and the reason I think the
Dutch farmers are bellwethers or
canaries in the coal mine is because
they are so-called ordinary competent
people hyper-competent people and
they're shaking their fist in the air
saying look you're demolishing our
livelihoods here while you're pursuing
your your virtue signaling
self-aggrandizing
um hyper moral goals and not only are
you not accomplishing those goals you're
actually working at counter purposes to
them like the German government has
managed on the energy front and so we're
seeing a a danger of a very intrusive
form of global governance and that's as
you said is taking priority all over all
national local and individual concerns
and that that's a huge danger and I
don't think people are cognizant of that
all at at all yet lost as in the as they
are in this delusion that we're doing
something like serving the environment
right it's a very very simple narrative
but so what do you see though you know
you made a bit of a case there for the
beneficial
um motives of some of the globalists at
least in relationship to these goals but
there's a nefarious element to what's
going on what do you think the what do
you think the the fundamental intent is
you know like I worry old statements
like the planet has too many people on
it and we've exceeded the carrying
capacity of the biosphere
etc etc which sound to me like
implicitly
murderous they're it's essentially
murderous sentiment or suicidal but what
do you think what do you think the
intent of the globalists is if you had
to give the devil is due yes okay so
globalists I mean obviously there are
people so the the flaws that are in our
human Souls the want for power and money
lives inside of them as well and they
want to do it on a global scale so the
biggest evil I would say imaginable gets
its chance if you let the globalists
take rule
um so what do you want to do if you are
a globalist who wants to you know open
up all borders
um have essentially the biggest consumer
base in the world which is the entire
world right well then things like
Christianity national identity cultural
identity are just things that stand in
your way if you want to create the
perfect consumer then you want somebody
who doesn't know who he is who doesn't
know what he stands for you know uh
um a devout Christian for example who
wants nothing more than to start a
family and work hard and live for God is
not going to be the perfect consumer
that sits on his couch watches Netflix
all day orders his food from ubereats uh
you know and does nothing more than that
does nothing more than just consume so I
think that the it's for me at least it's
hard not to see again there the question
of intent you know of trying to uproot
people so that they are confused and
aimless Souls that will buy what these
globalists offer and do as they say and
I think that that is exactly what we are
witnessing today most of us are turning
into perfect consumers without a higher
purpose oh well you sound when you talk
like that you sound more like Joe Rogan
or Russell Brand which maybe even Bernie
Sanders you know these people on the
left who are still genuine leftists in
some sense who are hyper concerned about
corporate gigantism which I think is a
genuine a genuine element of concern and
what you're seeing expressing is an
Unholy and I would say truly fascist
level of collusion between
corporate Giants who are essentially
motivated by very little else and a kind
of self-serving greed and and maybe
which might work at a local level when
there's lots of competition but when
they're large enough to engage in
regulatory capture and to engage in
collusion with government and media that
poses another one of these Tower of
Babel threats to all of us and so that
ties back into Michael what Michael had
brought up earlier all the snakes that
he'd
um what would you say exposed underneath
the carpet so Michael I I made the case
to Eva that you could you could argue
that um
you could you could attribute intent to
the globalists merely as a consequence
of their desire to mask their
incompetence with virtue signaling to
the masses and then you could say
corrupted by their
unrecognized greed on the corporate
front and all the dark motivations that
that puts in place for government
corporate collusion but you're pointing
to something that's more nefarious and
as they say uh in the scientific
Community extraordinarily extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence so
I don't know anything except for what
we've talked about briefly about this
Tri-City hypothesis and that seems to be
like I wouldn't want to wander down that
rabbit hole unless it was absolutely
necessary given that there's already
alternative it's not a hypothesis you're
very well this is that that's what I
want you to make the map that and tell
people why web searched Tri-State City
and you'll see the map instantly they've
got it mapped out we would be sitting
right in the middle of it right here the
map is mapped out they're doing uh
research to make it now and I when I see
Trump talking about beautiful cities I
mean it sounds like Tri-State city which
is a smart city which is meant for
complete control I mean they're they're
already doing at brainport city and
their experiment I've been to brainport
City over there looking at think look we
could have the same con I'm going to
Japan again next week again I've written
three books that are only in Japanese
about the subject and I'm going there
again next week we could have this exact
same discussion if we take this to the
orbital view the exact same discussion
in Japan and the details would sound
almost like they do here like little
details they don't talk about stick
stuff nitrogen but they talk about other
things for instance Ava Ava could be
masako ganaha and she would be saying
the exact same things except with little
details okay so in Canada
Google attempted okay in Canada Google
attempted to collude with the Ontario
government to to make the New Port
development in Toronto into a smart City
and a a person I know well who knows
more about technological issues and
issues of potential technological
control probably than anybody I've ever
talked to in the world more or less
fought that to a standstill so that
Google didn't get their hands on the
port development in Canada and his
primary concern was that what Google
essentially wanted was all the data that
would be generated as a consequence of
constant monitoring of absolutely
everything that went on in the Smart
City because that data is part of the
extended digital self and has tremendous
commercial value because if I can track
you in all your purchases and where are
you growing and where you are I can
Target you for marketing in a way that's
been unheard of up until now and so
that's a that's a huge can of worms and
in any case that didn't happen in Canada
but now it it's reminiscent to me as
well
uh of what's happening in the UK most
particularly in Oxford and Cambridge in
relationship to the 15-minute cities now
the 15-minute cities are put forward as
a solution to the problem of undue
distance to travel and so the idea is
that wouldn't it be lovely if we had
walkable neighborhoods where everything
you needed was within easy reach and you
know I have some sympathy for that
because I've gone to monoculture suburbs
let's say that are nothing but row upon
row upon row of identical houses with no
churches and no bars and no community
centers and you know the shopping
centers at a distance and that doesn't
look like an optimal Urban model but I
looked into the C40 websites the C40 is
the Consortium of municipalities that
have signed on to the 50-minute city
plan and I read in their own
documentation this is relevant to the uh
Tri-State City idea that their goals are
to reduce caloric caloric consumption to
2500 calories Day by by force
essentially within the next 15 years to
ensure that the peasant class which is
everybody but the elitists can't fly
more than one time every three years to
not merely shift Private Car ownership
from fossil fuel to Electric which is
fundamentally impossible because the
grid can't handle it but to eliminate 90
percent of of Private Car ownership so
that people are forced to take you know
unbelievably expensive in terms of time
utilization and non-existent public
transportation systems and to limit the
amount of travel that people can do
outside of their neighborhoods and you
know I find and then I watch The Legacy
Media claim that pointing that out is
something akin to a right-wing Wing
conspiracy which it most certainly isn't
because you can just find the bloody
documentation online and then I look at
places like China which have taken this
to an extreme
400 600 million closed circuit TV
cameras in China One for every one and a
half persons watching the Chinese all
the time able to monitor them 100 by
face and also to identify them by gate
and and to limit their ability to do
absolutely anything to buy to sell to
travel to move to leave their
neighborhood with this top-down
surveillance system that perversely and
consciously the some of the Chinese
Engineers have actually named Skynet and
in a conscious attempt to produce a
positive version of you know the
absolutely catastrophic apocalyptic
artificial intelligence that was in the
bloody Arnold Schwarzenegger movies and
you can't even talk about this stuff
without sounding like a raving
conspiratorialist but but there it is
now tell me more about the Tri-State
City so what have you seen because I
don't know anything about it neither
does anybody else watching I presume
except for you know those who've gone
down the rabbit hole with you
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripts memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible Bible
printed on the Press of Johann goonberg
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away with
at least a sense of that
you know you know I love to read
voraciously on pandemic because I'm a
war correspondent and pandemic famine
award they go together right they are
co-sanguinated and I was reading a book
about cholera a couple of years ago I
think it was called ghost map and uh and
interestingly towards the end of the
book he Lo the the author in an
otherwise excellent book started talking
about these smart cities where you know
basically everything we don't have to
worry about any disease anymore that
sort of thing last time I was in China
uh you know I got kicked out of Hong
Kong in 2020 I was a bad boy I was
watching the protest and they finally
kicked me out after seven months but
that was Hong Kong but when I was the
last time I was in mainland China I was
actually uh researching information more
I was in places like Nanjing and
Shanghai and that sort of thing but I
was in southern China uh where the
uyghurs are uh for part of that trip and
I I was talking with restaurant owners
and farmers and that sort of thing and
the restaurant various restaurant owners
told me that when a uyghur comes in they
are mandated by law to call the police
immediately the police immediately come
to check so the Smart City goes beyond
mere Optics you know they're installing
those cameras all over Hong Kong they
were doing it that when I left that's in
Hong Kong but over in mainland China
it's not just the cameras everywhere
it's also you know you're mandated to
call when I was in Hong Kong by the way
in the protest the the protesters would
take their lasers and shine them in the
cameras and and burn out the sensors
actually my camera got a little damaged
by it and but you know that's not a
long-term solution obviously but the
what I'm getting to is these smart
cities are clearly coming and they're
already here to some degree every time
we use our cards and that sort of thing
but they're clearly taking it to a
higher level of complete control and
again they this isn't conspiratorial
they say they're going to do it and we
talk about Margarita the Prime Minister
of Netherlands you can see Cloud Schwab
going where do you find such Prime
Ministers as Margarita you know did you
see him saying I I watch your Twitter uh
Jordan and I and I watch a lot of your
podcast I know you know what's going on
because you talk about it all the time
you you attack Trudeau it seems like
every two hours right I mean you you
know exactly what's happening this is
that's because I don't have enough time
to do it more yeah well I know it
digital currency front I mean well one
of the things we should point out to
everybody who's watching and listening
is that we're already three quarters of
the way down the digital currency
pipeline because there isn't really much
difference between a credit card or a
bank card and digital currency and the
reason I say there's not much difference
is because when you use a credit card or
a bank card to make a transaction
there's a digital record of the
transaction and then that digital record
can be brokered and so far mostly it's
brokered to other corporations which
isn't as totalitarian as it might be
because so far most corporations just
want your money so they can sell you
things now that can be problematic
because you can have things pushed on
you by what you call corporations that
are going a little bit farther than they
should that you don't really need or
want but at least you get something out
of the bargain but once we're fully
digital in our currency that'll mean the
government would be able to track
absolutely every bloody thing you ever
do and also be able to do things like
they're already doing in China so they
the Chinese government has put expiry
dates on some digital currency so they
you know if they need to have the
population spend more let's say because
there is a recession they could just put
in an edict that would make sure that
your money depreciated by two percent
every month
so that that would be an impetus to
spending and uh and they could do the
reverse if they wanted you to save and
so it means it means in potential the
emergence of a system for comprehensive
control that's so complete that we can
barely imagine it and you know we might
say well isn't that paranoid and I would
say uh look we still think we were in a
covid epidemic what we were really in
was an epidemic of imitating the Chinese
Communists and we ran to imitate them as
fast as we possibly could and that
Chinese Communist Regime they just
re-elected ji Zing ping the other day
um with a
2952-0 margin for the next five years
the probability that he's president for
life is extraordinarily high and so we
are in danger of using the Chinese
Communist party and it's wanted
efficiencies on the energy and
environment front as a model for
totalitarian governance across the world
you know we thought when we integrated
China into the world economy that the
Chinese would turn into Western a West
democracy but what's happening instead I
would say is that because we've invited
the Chinese to the table we're turning
into the CCP yeah and people are
certainly not and we're doing it under
the guise of this idiot protect the
virginal Planet environmentalism that's
all motivated by this what would you say
fear-mongering apocalypse apocalypse
that's probably the fundamental that's
probably the fundamental question of our
time so that's why we have to say no to
all of these things we have to say no to
cbdc's we have to say no to digital
identity we have to say no to 15-minute
cities because they're all the same
thing but it's problematic it's hard in
Western Society in the mind of modern
men nowadays to tell them that you know
those nice little pretexts that they use
to sell this to us are not actually the
truth we need a return to real ethical
debate about where we want to go as a
civilization and that's why it's so
important I think what you are trying to
do also with an alternative to something
like the world economic Forum because
those discussions are not being held we
are being sold Lies We are being sold
false premises pretext and we are forced
to debate within that Circle of Lies
oftentimes and it's the exact same thing
with the Dutch Farmers you know that's
why they're all all these subjects are
related to each other because they're
all a matter of are we going to give up
our freedom for a bit of convenience or
for you know those nice words that they
try to sell us and I think the answer
should be absolutely not but it's hard
yeah yeah well and then on the digital
currency front and Eve I'll turn to this
alternative that you described in a
minute on the digital currency front I
think something like a digital currency
is inevitable because we're already
three quarters of the way there and the
only real alternative I can see to the
top down centralized digital currency
that's being offered by the by the
governments in collusion let's say with
the wef is going to be something like a
decentralized system and it looks to me
like the best decentralized system
that's in place for currency at the
moment is Bitcoin and you know I don't
know if bitcoin's the solution but I
don't think any of the other electronic
coins digital currencies have the same
advantages or the same genuine radical
decentralization as Bitcoin and then Eva
you mentioned this alternative to the
wef that has been generated in the UK so
I'm going to release uh the statement of
vision for that Enterprise on my YouTube
channel tomorrow that's March 13th I'm
not sure when this will Air you know and
one of the things we're working through
is what the story that might unite us
might be and the story that we're being
presented right now is that human
activity especially at the industrial
level is intrinsically destructive in
relationship to pristine nature and has
to be limited by force if necessary
because there's a apocalyptic emergency
at hand and I do not believe for a
moment that there is a single
apocalyptic emergency at hand there may
be a multitude of them in many different
directions but to assume that it's a
mere consequence points let's say of
nitrogen over production or carbon
overproduction is a radical
oversimplification of pathological
magnitude and I also don't believe the
idea that limits to growth that are
opposed from the top down are the only
way that human beings can manage what
would you say harmonious relationships
with the broader broader biosphere I
think instead that if we got our
structures of governance put in place
properly like they generally are in free
Western countries that people could
cooperate well enough so that everyone
could be rich including the absolutely
poor around the world and that rich
people who have opportunity and a
certain degree of security would start
to attend to local environmental
concerns in a manner that would make the
planet Greener and more sustainable I
think so I think we could have our cake
and eat it too in this Enterprise you
described which is the alliance for
responsible citizenship is going to have
its inaugural Conference October 31st
November 1st to November 2nd I hope you
two can attend and with a big public
right in the middle of it that we hope
to bring twenty thousand approximately
twenty thousand people to but we're
trying to put forward a vision of
abundance and freedom and let's say
um environmental stewardship so mature
mature relationship and so that's
definitely underway and we have a lot of
people
a lot of public a lot of the public have
already clambered on board I've got a
mailing list of about 40 000 people and
we have a large number of of
well-positioned cultural
artistic business and political leaders
on board as well we're trying not to
make it into the latest Enterprise for
the reasons that we've already described
and I think everybody who's part of the
core group really is afraid of elitist
Enterprises and also concerned that any
attempts on the international level are
likely to turn into nothing but an
elitist Enterprise but we're at least
going to try to put forward a vision
that's much more voluntary and
decentralized and positive than this
bloody top-down Tower of Babel's
centralized apocalypse narrative that
everybody's being force-fed now it's so
it's so funny to me always how they
attack the minds of our of people
reading and especially young minds from
both ways it's on the one hand this
apocalyptic like the whole world is
going to come to an end a really
alarmist story and then on the other
hand on the individual level it's an
anything goes story everything is
relative you know there's just there's
your truth there's my truth there's
nothing such as an absolute truth you
know there's no God there's no no real
morality everything goes and that
combination is so incredibly deadly and
that's why I think it's so important
what you're doing with this and we need
to counter it what's absolutely right
Eva well you you get the worst so look
the the the the most intense and
totalitarian tyranny will necessarily
emerge in the midst of the most
fragmented and individualized population
and so and you see this on the identity
front you know because the radicals
claim now is that your identity is no is
nothing at all other than what you feel
it to be at this moment which is as
hedonistic and whim driven an identity
as you can possibly imagine and the
consequence of that isn't Freedom except
the freedom of idiot whim the
consequence is that you will 100 be 100
hand over all the responsibility that
you've abdicated to top down tyrants and
they will control every element of your
life you can't have a tyranny without
fractionated individuals and it is it is
a perverse marriage right of that
intense subjective so-called Freedom
with this insane top-down International
distant tyranny and we're definitely
drifting in that direction super fast go
ahead Mike that weaponized migration
again with massive people coming from
massive numbers of countries into places
like the United States and all across
the EU that creates that fracture not at
the
personal uh level in one mind but in in
the whole population you know nobody's
going to be able to come together you
aren't going to have Dutch farmers and
Netherlands they're going to be able to
stand up because they're going to be
replaced right and then you're going to
have a bunch of people from Somalia and
other places that are all mixed together
they'll they won't have any centralized
ability to organize perfect slaves I
mean this is very easy this is what they
say they're gonna do you've spent a lot
of time in
poverty-stricken in war-torn countries
and my suspicions are I don't want to
put words in your mouth that you've
developed a certain degree of what would
you say understanding of and empathy for
the world's poor and dispossessed and I
suppose the globalists who are
anti-border would make a case that the
poor people around the world should have
the opportunity to come to the west and
flourish and so and when you speak of
the danger of migration then it's easy
to paint you as someone who's you know
anti-third world and anti-ethnic
minority and but there is a real problem
of poverty around the world and so
what's your sense about how that poverty
could be properly ameliorated around the
world without that poverty without us
falling into this like homogenized
globalist utopian fractionated
individual trap
well keep in mind I've spent more than
half of my life overseas outside of the
United States more than half of my life
in about 90 countries right so I
understand that some fish just don't mix
well in the same aquariums right I mean
uh there's some you know if you had a uh
the aquarium fish chart there are some
fish like like let's say Filipinos that
are green green green green yellow they
don't get along with Filipinos as well
but green Filipinos get along with
everybody right they just they're like
the universal donor in Blood and then
there's chechens red red red red red red
right some don't get along very well
with each other for instance when I was
in the migrant camps in Lithuania I
asked specifically do you have any
churches and they said yes we keep them
separately I said what's the critical
mass in other words how many they said
well actually we have a critical mass we
never have more than six chechins
together if if you have seven chechins
or more it's kind of a joke but it's not
they go super critical right they become
a gang right and a lot of something that
a lot of people don't understand is that
you're not importing individuals you're
importing like Somali tribes or Nigerian
tribes when you meet a Nigerian like I
was with a Nigerian a few months ago in
Ireland and I and I asked him what
people he was from was it the Igbo or
whatever you know what I was asking
there's different groups over there and
you know he the the Nigerians don't come
and get together with Nigerians they
come and get together with people from
their tribe right so when you have
Kurdish people come in I love the Kurds
I'm out with Kurds a lot when I'm over
in that part of the world or yazidis
I've spent a lot of time with yazidis up
in Nineveh province in Iraq and I've met
some yazidis in the camps over in uh in
Lithuania for instance and one's still
there he messages me stuck in a camp and
actually he doesn't even speak English
he speaks German so we have to
communicate in German he lived in
Germany before the point is some of
these people get along very well others
come in as gangs or they become gangs
later right and this is designed to
split us apart now of course we can
always take migrants in and we should
but we should take them in and the
amount that can actually sort of
dissolve within our or at least become
time to time to digest let's say but
this is weaponized the integrate this is
weaponized that's what Stalin did in the
Lattimore in 1932-33 and well actually
before and after that as well that's
what that's what Mao did always trying
to get rid of these base groups that
have some cultural identity the farmers
you got I keep telling Dutch Farmers
because I'm looking at this from the
orbital view because I go from country
to Country and I'm looking for patterns
and they're very like I said we could go
to Japan and you would hear the same
conversation only the little details
would change and they're trying to
prepare the Japanese actually to bring
in migrants and the Japanese are some
are falling for it for instance if you
go to Okinawa well they have a
demographic they have a demographic
collapse in Japan so you know the
Japanese haven't managed to reproduce
enough to keep their young population at
a sufficient number likely to support
their industrial Enterprise across time
and China has is exactly the same
problem I mean do you think Japan has
any option other than to open itself up
to a certain degree of immigration
certainly I mean encourage the kids to
have more babies I mean you know to get
married well you know what I'm saying
yes well very few countries have managed
that you know Hungary has tried that
quite assiduously and they've managed to
stop the decline in birth rate and raise
it slightly but it's proved very
difficult for Western countries to
encourage young people to reproduce
enough to you know surpass that
replacement that replacement barrier
that's another problem we're trying to
address with this Alliance for
responsible citizenship I was there last
year checking it out in Hungary I mean
it's clear problem it's absolutely true
that it's a very very hard question to
solve but the answer can never be a
solution that doesn't work I mean the
mass migration of radically different
cultures especially to Europe has proven
to be very very unsuccessful and
something that the majority at least of
Western well most Western countries are
actually against but they are never
heard their questions are never answered
so democracy in that sense already does
not function we don't have borders they
are not protected and the consequences
have been quite I would say quite
detrimental for any major European city
and the answer to poverty in other parts
of the world I don't think can ever be
Let's Have All the Young you know
capable men move abroad you know or move
continent even how are they going to
build those countries up themselves so I
don't think that it's a solution for
Europe nor is it for example for Africa
no and also we're setting uh we're just
you know there's this demographic
demographic demise of course that's
happening with Russia as well in many
countries right uh not in the United
States but but in some countries it's
obviously a problem but does that mean
it's the end of Japan no it doesn't mean
that you know it's not it's non-sequitur
to think hey they don't have a
sufficient replenishment rate so
therefore we should bring in a bunch of
somalis I mean they're just like were
they that's like I have a headache so
let me pour gas on myself right it just
doesn't work so Michael let's turn to
this Tri-State City again because I'm
still unclear as to its function and
purpose and so tell me in some detail
what the Tri-State city is and and then
let's turn to more practical
considerations again on the farmer
protest front if if you don't mind so
tell me a bit more about the Tri-State
City plan
Tri-State city is a it's a they've
already mapped it out they're starting
to build it now they have to take out
your Farmers for multiple reasons one is
that also undermines the entire culture
of Netherlands the Dutch will cease to
exist other than in museums right uh and
so I like the cool locks in Ukraine
right uh and so uh
that then you can take their land the
Dutch arguably own or the Farmers
arguably about 62 percent of the land
I'm not sure this number is a moving
number and uh and I'm not sure what the
true numbers are is that about right and
yeah even a little bit higher yeah I
mean okay uh so anyway say 60 to 70
percent the highest number I've seen is
70. uh so you need that land to make
Tri-State City because most of
Netherlands is obviously a farm and so
but as you've pointed out before Jordan
you've said this last year why would you
replace the most efficient farmers in
the world or arguably among the most
efficient farmers in the world to start
there's going to be a nitrogen problem
all right but it's not a stick stuff
gift or poison gift is a German word for
poison it's not a poison problem there's
not going to be enough nitrogenous
fertilizers we talked about that in
regard to BASF fertilizer plant over in
Ludwig's half in Germany where I went to
twice last year last week they announced
reducing 2 600 more workers you and I
talked about this at length last year
and they just announced it last week and
they're cutting off one of their ammonia
plants and and uh and so this is a
there's there's definitely going to be a
nitrogen problem there's not going to be
enough nitrogenous fertilizers for
instance a pig farmer I was at here in
Netherlands last week uh he he was happy
that he said his his system is circular
he takes the pig poop and he fertilizes
the Christmas trees and the pear trees
with it I think or maybe just a pear
trees but he said it's circular so it's
you know it's quite uh good I said where
do you get your pig feed he gets it from
Brazil where does Brazil get their
nitrogenous fertilizers you remember the
gentleman we had dinner with last year
an old CEO of a Dutch uh a chemical
plant DSM he said Brazil gets their
fertilizers from Europe and Brazil he
told us at dinner they're not going to
have enough fertilizer this year and as
you know the United States gets a lot of
our protein from Brazil so and India's
got the same problem you know after you
and I met in Netherlands I flew over to
Ireland and talked with Mary Lou
McDonald the leader of shin Fein and all
she wanted to talk about was equity and
bringing in migrants you know and I
didn't want to talk about food or energy
so I flew over to London and I heard the
same story again I flew to Thailand and
I was having coffee with the next prime
minister I miss it I know him from old
days you can see me and him flying
around back during the fighting days and
I have an office in Thailand and I said
you know you've got problems you're
going to have problems you get you
import 92 percent if you're not
trogynous fertilizers you only create
eight percent and that's five million
metric tons that you may not be able to
get sometime in 2023 may not it's
unknown and if you can't he said oh
Michael you know we export x amount of
rice I'm well I'm well aware of that how
much rice you export however rice is
basically a nitrogen vacuum it sucks out
the nitrogen into the rice and you
export that nitrogen Thai soil is very
poor in nitrogen you have to have that
nitrogenous fertilizer where are you
going to get it from he's said we'll get
it from China I'm like uh check it out
you're not getting it from China right
now and you're not going to get it from
Russia or at least it's very seriously
in doubt if you can get it from Russia
you're not going to get it from Europe
where are you going to get it from
you're going to be bidding against Japan
Japan needs it too Malaysia cut off the
natural gas I mean this is a big I'm
looking at this from the orbital view
from the orbital view we've talked about
food issues before you're no more
optimistic you're no more optimistic on
the fertilizer side than you were a year
ago when we spoke I mean you know the
winter hasn't been as catastrophic as we
had bandied back and forth for a variety
of different reasons and the energy
crisis didn't come to well hey fair
enough but you're still convinced that a
fertilizer shortage so radical increase
in fertilizer prices at the minimum is
in the offing sometime in the next what
year or two years and and why are you
still convinced of that Michael well as
you know food prices are not elastic I
was meeting with Dutch farmer just the
other day at his he has 17 Acres of
greenhouses it's obviously massive and I
asked him about that and he said yes I
didn't ask him about actually about
famine ask him what he thought you know
how's the future look with food and he
said he'd talk about a hunger's note
which in Dutch's famine right and uh and
so uh and so he talked about this famine
and he and I said you know what's the
time window and he said well probably
four to five years and this guy has
actually started selling electricity he
just bought a generator from France a
diesel generator and and he's a farmer
but he saw that the the windmills and
the solar that is all over the place
here uh you know solar what months does
that actually work in what starts in
maybe May I'm not even sure but I mean
there's solar pet you've seen them
Jordan there's a massive amount of solar
panels in a place I mean if this was
Florida it'd make complete sense but you
know the windmills outside of his office
when I just met him were not spinning so
I said when do you sell electricity back
to the grid I mean I see those windmills
aren't spinning he said well I look out
my window and those windmills are not
spinning and it's cloudy I'm making
money so he talked about he just bought
he was renting a generator for 75 000 a
month he said he's making a couple
hundred thousand dollars a month off of
it at that point he just returned that
generator just bought two more and he
just bought a third one this one from
France which he's about to install so he
has he has these computer screens which
he allows is he contributing to the grid
is he contributing directly to the grid
how is he selling the electricity oh he
he has he has these computer screens he
let me video on me it was okay with him
uh you know if I published the video
which I haven't done yet but I can send
it to you but he's got these basically
two screens in particular and it shows
the the price of the of every minute it
updates so at any minute he might start
selling electricity so as soon as it
goes below this one uh line which the
line is moving based on how much his
diesel cost and how much the electricity
cost at that minute as soon as it goes
below that line he dumps his one
megawatt hour or I think it was a one
megawatt uh uh actually electrical
engineers helped me out uh battery which
he that met that huge battery dumps out
in 20 minutes but while that battery is
dumping out he's starting his generators
and as soon as the price goes above that
line he turns them off recharges the
battery and so multiple times a day he's
turning on the generators and turning
them back off but he's making a fortune
he told me that that that generator that
he's about to pay or he just paid 400
450 000 Euros about 475 000 he said he
should get a full return on investment
in four months he said three to four
months so let's say four months you know
so he's already stopped growing some of
the so he's good today right right so
he's concerned about energy reliability
and also about fertilizer availability
oh yeah right right got it got it so so
um I want to know a little bit more
about the farmers so you guys indicated
that there's somewhere between five and
ten thousand Farmers protesting can you
tell us the nature of those protests
like how many tractors are involved what
cities are they in what are they doing
to what effect is this having on Dutch
Society practically and metaphysically
and what are the farmers plans oh so
last summer there were massive protests
going on that were quite
um I would say for Dutch standards quite
radical quote unquote and I don't mean
that in a negative sense of the word but
just the fact that they went out in such
fast numbers was something that we don't
often see in our country so for example
the word folder culture is very telling
for who we are as a nation that sort of
signifies something like We're a nation
of compromise We're a nation of dialogue
um you know one of our favorite sayings
is like oh just behave normally then
you're already acting crazy enough that
is really typical for the Dutch so to
have all these Dutch farmers in the
summer go out in protest take their
tractors onto the highway for example
block the highway block distribution
centers even go towards the airport and
basically show our government who is
boss because that is really what they
did you know within a day we saw food
shortages in the supermarket so it
really reminded of people of the fact
that farmers you know produce our food
they're not just businessmen they
produce our everyday nutrition for us
and they were really successful with
those protests a bit too successful and
then what happened was the Dutch state
intervened so they sent police forces
they sent um actually the military to
those protests and at a certain point
they even started using violence and
shot at a 16 year old boy that was
driving away from the protest and mind
you these protests are completely
peaceful so we don't you know obviously
in the Netherlands we don't have Amazon
video from multiple angles that boy
didn't do anything that boy didn't do
anything he was 16 years old he was on a
tractor and he was driving away that
should not happen in a free western
country and the fact that it did happen
and the fact that we don't have a First
Amendment and we definitely don't have a
second amendment became very very
apparent to me what do you do in that
type of situation when you are dealing
with a government that thinks that it
can take away everything that you have
ever worked for everything that you have
ever done in your entire life just like
this because they create a crisis out of
thin air and they say you have to give
up your eyes you have to give up your
property and we're just going to take
your land because mind you our farmers
are not free to sell their lands to the
market you know it has to go to the
states so again that shows you I think
the state's true intent okay so I didn't
know that so tell me that okay so tell
me that tell me that again
yeah so no the the all these nitrogen
policies the consequence of those are
always either voluntary selling which
like we just discussed is never really
actually voluntary you know you could be
pointing a gun at me from that room and
then I could say oh yeah here's my you
know here's my property is that
voluntary no of course not you know
that's that's basically a metaphor for
what is happening with the farmers right
now and otherwise it's going to be
expropriation forceful buyouts if they
don't say yes now it will become forced
later on during the next couple of years
so just that fact alone that they are
not you know allowed to sell their Farms
to the market for maybe even potentially
a better price should tell you all that
you need to know right right okay so
what effect is the
um are the farmers protests having on
Dutch Society practically and and and
conceptually are the Dutch people you
claimed earlier that the Dutch people
are on the side of the Farmers which
begs the question then why do you have
the government that you have you know if
if that's so clearly the case and is
there a backlash against the farmer's
protests and what are they doing to
Dutch Society like are they shutting
what are they shutting down what's the
effect on food production and on public
confidence Etc well after those protests
in the Summer where they shot at the boy
and you know the protest became more and
more heated the mainstream media did
exactly what our government wants it to
do and they started vilifying our
farmers and you know they are trying to
test the people's patients so when
things go on for too long especially in
the Netherlands people get tired of it
you know the news cycle they're like oh
these Farmers again the government
starts saying we need to renegotiate
like I said the renegotiations never
lead to anything they just change the
tune but they their aim is their hope is
that people will get tired of it and
sadly that was the case so for a couple
of months after the Dutch farmers were
worldwide new use during the summer we
didn't hear anything from our Farmers
for the longest time and there are a lot
of farmers that are still because you
know usually that is a good Dutch
mindset open to dialogue open to
negotiations you know they were they
were willing to sit around the table
with our government again and then when
the new report came out and nothing
changed uh the mainstream media again
started ramping it up and I think a lot
of people got afraid they got fearful a
lot of farmers that they had lost the
support of the people because if they
read what the mainstream papers write
about them then if I were them I would
also think that they that I had no
support from the Dutch people anymore
but I think inherently the opposite is
true I think if you ask most people on
the street in Holland do you think that
this is right they will say no I don't
think that that is right but they don't
quite make the next step where they
translate that into this government is
actually what they're doing is actually
criminal you know I don't want to do
that they they're still stuck in that
lie of well you know if there's really a
crisis then maybe we should do something
maybe we should negotiate a little bit
whereas I personally have made it my
mission to say none of this is real it's
a political decision we should not
negotiate with people who are driving
our Farmers to well to Despair and who
want to take away their lands their
thiefs you know if a thief comes into my
house I will not go and negotiate with
them and say well please don't take my
laptop but you can take the TV are we
good now you know of course you would
never do that but with the government
people expect our Farmers to do it and I
think that is the strategy like I said a
war of attrition they to try to drag it
out so long well so if you can't
negotiate in good faith because your
partners aren't negotiating in good
faith What alternative is left for the
Dutch farmers and what's the plan I mean
they they're they're bringing their
tractors on Moss to what cities where
are the protests taking place right now
now well they were all over the country
really during the summer and now we had
a rally yesterday that was at the Hague
and that was because the Hague is where
our Parliament resides and we have
elections coming up in a couple of days
those are Regional elections but they
are imported because they dictate what
our Senate looks like so if our Senate
changes in uh you know in composition
and if the cabinet the current cabinet
loses its majority then obviously new
legislation will not pass so it is
incredibly important that this happens
right now and they were but the farmers
were very afraid leading up to this this
rally that we had yesterday this protest
that we had yesterday to even take their
tractors because the mayor of the Hague
said you cannot bring your tractors
which I think is a massive violation of
our right to protest because you know
tractors are not weapons but they
civilize who the farmers are you have to
stop asking for permission freedom is
not granted freedom is taken I agree by
any means necessary the the piety means
necessary that's sounds familiar these
days they the Dutch Farmers have to go
full French you know the French what
happens when you push French Farmers you
know the the the the French government
is terrified of their Farmers I used to
think the French farmers were wrong to
protest every little thing like you know
when I go to France and you know the
farmers will give you an earful and uh
but now I realize the wisdom of their
ways oh yeah absolutely you've got to go
full French and go if you play defense
you are absolutely going to lose and you
cannot compromise with this it's like
you said it's like compromising with a
robber you have to go full on and uh and
be offensive and I don't mean kill
people but I mean do it the way the
French do it the French Farmers aren't
out killing people but they'll sure
block the roads and terrify the
government they'll terrify them at the
election polls uh and it works yeah I'm
gonna go back to France and learn some
more of their tricks so this is you know
my last hope with the farmers is that
they will start to see this so obviously
we're now going to wait and see what
happens during the elections but I've
personally don't have much hope because
sadly a lot of people don't realize you
know that our governing Party The vvd
margaritas party they say that they are
right wing you know they're the typical
neoliberal globalists of this world and
a lot of people who don't read any
alternative media will still think that
that's true and they think that that's a
fairer party to vote for so I'm I'm not
hopeful that this time around
you know that they will lose their
majority actually so then the next
question is what will they do what will
the farmers do are they going to stay
afraid of the demonization and the
vilification that is going on in the
mainstream Media or will they say enough
is enough we don't want to negotiate
anymore and we will indeed bring our
government to its knees because they
have the manpower to do it they are just
afraid to use it if they do it again I
will I honestly I think that if the
Dutch farmers were for example to block
the road to the the port in the in in
Rotterdam our Haven there and if the
fishermen would come from the other side
and the Dock Workers will say we stopped
working within a week Margarita will be
brought to his knees I'm 100 convinced
of that because then they'll start to
feel okay so so okay okay so that's
starting to get you know that's starting
to those those options are starting to
become quite radical and I'm I'm not
saying anything positive or negative
about that at the moment just pointing
that out I do have a question though is
that if the Dutch government is bringing
the police bringing the police and the
military to bear on the farmers why are
the police and the military cooperating
because my sense for example in Canada
was that among the military and the
police there was a tremendous amount of
support for the Canadian Truckers
fundamentally you know because they're
the same people all things considered
and and nonetheless the military and the
police did their Bettors bidding which
is of course what should happen in a
state that's still functioning property
but in Holland
um to what degree are the police and the
military as far as you can tell aligned
with the government compared to to what
degree are they aligned in a more true
sense with the farmers and the fishermen
and the Dock Workers so on a lower level
what I've noticed yesterday for example
at the protest as well the police
officers that we have encountered were
all incredibly friendly and you could
just tell that they loved what we were
doing I think that that is probably
sadly the reality of our police forces
the officer on the street supports the
farmers but this the top level listens
to the establishment and obviously those
are the people that call the shots and
so younger generation police officers
are afraid to lose their job if they
stand up against it and obviously you
don't you only need a couple of Really
Brave and courageous souls to make make
some good shots in in those cases with
the protests but
sadly I think the majority
um just listens to whomever gives them
orders and the top layer of the police
forces isn't in the pocket of the state
okay so so what would you suggest that
people who are watching and listening in
the Netherlands what is it that they
could do to make their concerns known
and how could they express support for
the Dutch farmers and and the same thing
applies on a broader scale there's going
to be people all over the world watching
this podcast what would you recommend to
people who are watching and listening so
that they can stay properly apprised of
what's actually going on in the
Netherlands given that the Legacy Media
is corrupt Beyond Comprehension like how
do people inform themselves properly and
what would the Dutch Farmers want to see
and need to see in terms of support from
people around the world so I think that
the international support has been
incredibly important to the Dutch
Farmers
um because they've seen you know that
the world is watching and that they
understand that this is something that
will eventually you know not just stay a
Dutch issue but will spread and and
could affect others other nations other
people around the world so that support
has been incredibly vital
um what the Dutch people can do first of
all they can go and vote vote the
current parties out of at least the
Senate that would be incredibly
important of course in favor of who in
favor of who well true opposition
parties there are a few left
um I will not sit here and tell people
who to vote for but I would say if any
of these parties are in favor of
negotiating about the nitrogen crisis or
and or expropriating our Farmers you
shouldn't vote for them that's that's
very simple and I think it's a losing
strategy that's a negotiate the power of
symbolism is very very important very
strong it's it doesn't take much to take
your Dutch flag put it on your you know
on your window and turn it upside down
signify that you are a nation in
distress it's become the symbol for the
Dutch Farmers protest for Farmers Canada
too on the trucker side exactly I think
for Farmers to see that you know that's
a silent sign of support I think will
will make them feel like they're not
alone can I say something I think that's
important yeah of course the the
Canadian Farmers uh they keep the Dutch
Farmers uh Canadian truckers Dutch
Farmers keep bringing them up them up
they did yesterday again the guys on
stage and whatnot the Canadian farmer
example then spread to America which I
went with our Canada our American
truckers all the way from California to
DC I rode all the way across the country
with them and now the Dutch Farmers talk
about the Canadians that spark was
important just no I'll leave it at that
courage is contagious it is that is
that's really what we need right now
Canadians led the way on that one and it
was really an important spark there were
a lot of Canadian flags yesterday at the
rally too yeah there were absolutely
because they understand that we're all
in the same boat you know the world's
upside down when Dutch farmers are
protesting and Canadian truckers take
the political lead I mean something
seriously going astray well first of all
when Canada is even interesting and you
know on the political scene and I would
say the same thing in some sense about
Holland I mean there are a few countries
I've ever visited that are more deeply
civilized in the most positive positive
possible sense than Holland it's an
absolutely amazing country an incredible
balance of beauty and freedom and order
you know and that's so difficult to
attain in Broad public trust and and all
all within that that great acceptance of
wide difference and wide range of
individual
um of potential for action it's an
amazing thing that you people have
accomplished as people like Diane herzi
Ali have been at Point pains to point
out and the same can be said on a
somewhat lesser scale of Canada but then
when you see the people who are in fact
the competent hard-working backbone on
the manual labor and productivity side
the truckers and the farmers rise up and
say you know government has become so
intolerable that we can no longer do our
job then everyone who's awake in the
least whether they're on the right or
the left should wake up and think oh my
God you know the people who normally do
nothing but put their nose to the
grindstone are complaining perhaps
something seriously wrong that well
there is something seriously wrong and
all if the Dutch Farmers lose man
there's going to be hell to pay because
they're courageous in the extreme
competent in the extreme and true
canaries in the coal mine and I think
the most likely outcome at the moment
sad to say is that that the Dutch
government will keep grinding away on
its in its incremental fashion and it
will pick them off one by one and
they'll reduce the damn Dutch farmer
population to 50 percent devastate the
agricultural sector and that'll produce
shock waves of dismay across the
otherwise Across the Western World among
those who might otherwise object and
it'll also produce a terrible
catastrophe on the food and tyranny
front so this is a watershed moment as
far as I'm concerned If This Were a lost
War I would not even be here they can
definitely win but they have to go
offensive they will absolutely lose if
they stay defensive and you talked about
the polder called tour which is the the
culture of negotiation and uh which the
anthropologists who specialized in
information who specialize in
information War they will find these
weaknesses in the culture like the
folder the polder called tour which is
you know fine compromise that's the same
in Japan that's the same with Canadians
the strongest part of the Canadian
culture and the Dutch culture and the
Japanese culture is it's highly
civilized that makes you highly
vulnerable to Savage those are well
Michael you know there are there are
simulations of this sort of thing that
have been played out biologists by
biologists on large scale trying to
account for the Persistence of
narcissism and psychopathy
machiavellianism and so forth that that
manipulative attitude and often
manipulative people and what happens is
if you produce a population of people
who do nothing but cooperate they can
cooperate like mad and that can be
extraordinarily productive but if you
drop a single shark into the tank a tank
full of Cooperators the shark takes
everything
and so on the one hand that willingness
to negotiate and agree can be The Driver
of Civil Society but the problem is is
that it opens up the it opens up a niche
for the manipulative Psychopaths to play
a winner take take all game and they do
do that ex precisely by exploiting the
weak part of cooperation go ahead yeah
that's why I don't mind in this day and
age you know where evil is so prevalent
to be called a radical I don't mind to
be called a radical in the fight against
evil and I think that is really the
fight that we're fighting right now so
to be moderate in the face of evil it
means that evil will win and our gov our
country uh thank you for your kind words
about my country because I completely
full heartedly agree with you we have
such a rich history we are such a
beautiful nation and yesterday at the
rally when I was giving my speech I said
this as well the fact that we have a
government that has launched an attack
on its own people you know that has
turned on its own people to me is some
of the worst kinds of Injustice that you
can find like imaginable and and so we
really need to put up a fight against
that captured government as is Trudeau
he's he's he's ruthless boy Margarita
here's prime minister
they're his this is a captured country
the government is captured it has it
cannot exist with this government I mean
this government is captured by the way
they call it the weft here right and the
weft and the CCP are co-sanguinated I
used to look at them as cooperating but
it's very clear that they're that
they're so entwined that they're one at
this point later they'll fight each
other but yeah it's very important to to
uh it's time to put your game faces on
you know what I mean it's time to stop
negotiating it's time to stop being
polite it's time to say you out and
that's it I mean you're going out one
way or the other or it's got or you're
going to lose and you're going to be
slaves
all right well that's probably
um a high note so to speak to end on
um very dismal and dark conversation in
many ways and but it's an extension of
the sorts of conversations we've had in
the past Michael and I do wish the Dutch
Farmers well I mean I really can't think
of a more reliable substrata of a more
reliable population in the world and so
when they're upset enough to take their
tractors to the Hague something rotten
is going on that's deep and pervasive
and and I think people around the world
should wake up and smell the coffee so
to speak before there's no coffee to
smell and we're closer to that than
people realize and so
um thank you very much for your time and
attention and contributions today and
for all the things that you're doing
around the world Michael and in
Netherlands the same to you Ava
appreciate you talking to me today for
all you watching and listening you know
keep your ears to the ground and your
eyes peeled because you should know what
the hell is going on in Europe in places
like Holland especially with regards to
this protest because there's something
Brewing there that's a mic microcosm of
a much larger struggle that's for sure
and so we're going to turn now to the
Daily wear plus side of the platform I'm
going to talk to Eva and Michael for
another half an hour uh delve a bit more
into their autobiographical history so I
can get to know them better
um thanks to the Daily wear plus people
for facilitating this conversation and
also for helping send Michael to the
Netherlands which was very helpful
obvious in relationship to this
conversation and uh
those of you who are watching might
consider popping over to the Daily wire
plus platform to catch the last half an
hour of of our interaction and uh all
right so thank you all to all who are
watching listening I'm in Puebla Mexico
at the moment thank you to the film crew
here for facilitating this that's much
appreciated and uh to all those of you
watching listening ciao and we'll see
you on the next podcast and then we'll
turn over to the to the next half hour
thanks very much Michael and Eva
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com